okay move out
bye
the vast and awesome body of water that
lies between america and asia
borders a wide variety of lands where
live a billion people
ranging from space age sophisticates to
the stone age aborigines of australia
this great sea stirred by epic currents
and by the legendary trade winds
inhabited by creatures as countless as
the sands
devastating in the anger of its typhoons
and tidal waves
is known by the gentle name pacific
with its more than 400 installations
throughout the widely scattered shores
of this ocean
west to asia and down to the south pole
the united states army pacific user pac
is deployed over 40 percent of the
earth's surface
user pack the largest overseas army
command in the free world
has ranged up to a strength of one half
million soldiers and 90 000 civilians
the command has its headquarters in the
beautiful island state of hawaii
near honolulu fort shafter for more than
60 years in army post
is today the headquarters for the united
states army pacific
although war seems remote here among the
orderly rows of venerable
palms this is in fact the fountainhead
of the activity of many
thousands of troops deployed over 12
million square miles of pacific lands
here concepts and plans are originated
and set in motion
distance is the constant enemy
vast quantities of supplies are needed
to support our troops
the 8 000 miles from san francisco to
saigon
takes 20 days by ship and 20 to 40 hours
by aircraft
the vital necessity of maintaining close
contact with units so dispersed
has been met by developing a remarkable
network of communication facilities
powerful transmitters and strangely
shaped antennas
transmit and receive a heavy flow of
messages
required by the army's massive
operations
to carry out its mission user pack has
set up seven subordinate
commands
us army hawaii japan
ryukyu islands
taiwan eighth u.s army korea
u.s army support command thailand
and vietnam
the headquarters for us army hawaii user
ha
is in famous schofield barracks it
directs the army's installations
throughout the state
user hall is prepared to receive station
and deploy
an entire division
hawaii based troops are made combat
ready for action in any area of the
pacific
by intensive training programs
the sounds of battle rebound from
mountains foreign
the hawaiian command also works with
national guard units
to provide air defense for the islands
they man the nike hercules sites
located strategically on the principal
islands
the national guard holds annual
maneuvers on the big island of hawaii
gaining skill with the weapons they
would use against any potential enemy
the army maintains a close relationship
with civil defense headquarters
located in the crater of diamond head
an elaborate underground labyrinth
stands ready for use in case of enemy
attack
or natural disaster
also in user hall command is tripler
army medical center
with 1 000 beds it is the most modern
armed forces hospital in the pacific
its patients come from all over the
pacific command and from all the
services
as the first major land base west of the
mainland
hawaii is an important army shipping
center
across its docks past the supplies and
hardware of war
nearly 4 000 miles away a u.s army
command is found
in japan
this great industrial nation
advantageously located in the western
pacific
makes a logical procurement center for
certain items
here in this quality testing lab
operated by us army japan
items are checked to make certain they
meet standards
many items the army buys are sent to
this lab
for study
not only are some new things purchased
in japan old equipment
is restored at an inventory control
point outside tokyo
unserviceable or damaged equipment from
korea vietnam and other pacific
countries
is rejuvenated
whenever further use is possible combat
vehicles are rebuilt
and tested for return to use
millions of dollars worth of supplies
and restored equipment is shipped every
year
to countries allied with us in the
military assistance program
to strengthen them against the communist
threat
u.s army transportation command is a key
factor in these
operations handling both new and old
inbound and outbound
in a gigantic endless flow of materiel
and supplies
basic necessities such as petroleum are
stockpiled for quick response when
needed
the armed forces far east network
broadcast the familiar sounds of home
style programming
for all americans in the area
the armed forces newspaper specific
stars and stripes
a lively tabloid-sized publication is
turned out daily in offices
located in tokyo
up to the minute world news is rushed by
air to men all over the pacific
stars and stripes prides itself on its
fast delivery to men
in the forefront of the far east
defenses
of great importance to the fighting men
are the fine hospital facilities
established in japan within practical
range of the war zone
with fast air transportation a routine
matter
patients given emergency treatment in
vietnam can be evacuated
in a few hours to japan
there intensive surgical and medical
care is readily available
in addition to fine surgical facilities
much
care and attention is given to physical
therapy
the retraining and strengthening of
muscles of seriously injured men
the reward comes when patients are able
to make it on their own
many men after a period of rest and
recuperation
are able to return to active duty with
their outfits
those requiring long recovery periods
are often sent by a helicopter
to a large air base where they are flown
back to the states
besides care of patients the army
doctors carry on a quiet war
fought in test tubes against such
insidious tropical diseases as
schistosomiasis
here hundreds of infected snails
carrying the deadly disease
are carefully tended to keep a constant
source of research material
for the progressive battle
a short distance from japan is korea
since 1950 it has been home to the
eighth u.s army
for the first three years it fought a
war here
in july of 1953 a truce was signed with
the communists
so that a peace treaty could be worked
out that was a long time ago
and the enemy is still unwilling to
negotiate
so all these many years later
replacements are still coming in at the
rate of almost 50
000 a year
in this land full of old memories punch
bowl
heartbreak ridge pork chop hill old
baldi
in which victory was won back from
apparent defeat
we are still facing an armed enemy there
in north korea
two u.s infantry divisions stand ready
to back up the south koreans
close to the dmz astride a traditional
invasion route to seoul
is our second infantry division geared
for instant action
patrols of the second are daily
searching the countryside for any sign
of infiltrators
these patrols are in deadly earnest
because infiltration
is a reality and these men never know at
what instant they
may be brought under fire by an enemy
ambush
the other us division on duty the
seventh stands by
on call to move its forces wherever
needed
exacting training and discipline keep
the men at the peak of readiness
members of the south korean army who
volunteer to serve within u.s
army units join in the training
quick response and self-reliance are
objects of this training
which includes improvised river
crossings of the kind that would be used
in combat conditions
a faster expedient the slide for life
practical experience is gained in
crossing korea's well-known rugged
mountains
it's faster coming down
in modern war planes are swift and
warning is short
seconds determine survival
members of anti-aircraft missile crews
rehearse the assignments they would
perform in an actual attack
these clockwork rehearsals shave missile
delivery time
the mighty missiles are ready to reach
for the sky
at all times eyes search the dmz and
nearby terrain
for any sign of enemy activity
many bunkers stand by that would be
quickly manned in time of combat
meanwhile news of the rest of the world
comes to our troops in korea
by newspaper and broadcast
which bring up to the minute news
flashes delivered to the military
audience by one of its own members
afkn radio reaches an even larger
audience
more hours of the day and night
these american programs are also winning
a new audience
but always there is a treacherous enemy
to be watched for
waited for through many a long hour day
and night
in a vigil that cannot be relaxed for an
instant
our soldiers scan the terrain at the dmz
to ensure that the hard one stability in
this part of the world
is maintained the growing standard of
living continues to grow
and the korean people continue to enjoy
the fruits of their freedom
a few hours away by air is another
important ally
in the defense of the pacific taiwan
with its principal city of taipei
although we have relatively few military
personnel
in the republic of china an important
liaison is maintained
by the military assistance advisory
group
planning for the defense of taiwan is an
important part of the job
the republic of china's army is highly
trained and works with determination to
reach its greatest potential
academically as well as militarily
this well-organized force is a major
deterrent to red china
the red leaders cannot make any move
without considering the reaction of
forces
on taiwan
coordination of training concepts is
important when troops of various nations
may have to work together
the mutual understanding of each other's
methods today
may well save lives tomorrow for the
extraordinarily complicated operations
of modern warfare
far greater knowledge and experience is
needed than at any other time
in history in the republic of china
the us army operates essential world
communications
for all the united states services
this switchboard can reach out across
the world through the strategically
placed network of u.s
stations
user pack's most western command is the
us army support command
thailand
for many years thailand has been a
nation undisturbed by wars and
revolutions that have troubled its
neighbors
but a shadow falls over the piece of
this lovely land today
communist leaders have made no secret
that thailand is a target for an
attempted takeover
the busy streets of the city show no
evidence of this threat
but the ties are gerding to defend
themselves and these crowded streets
do not lend themselves to the heavy
traffic of military preparations
with vast shipments of ammunition and
supplies
bangkok's harbor already filled to
capacity with the normal commerce of the
country
would bottleneck military shipping
so our army engineers helped to
construct an entirely new port complex
at sada heap an open country far away
from the congestion of the city
docking facilities began with a de long
floating pier
permanent deep water birds were
constructed under contract
making sada heap another main port of
entry for thailand
in addition large capacity fuel lines
were constructed
extending to anchored ships out over the
water so that fuel
pump directly from the ships can travel
by pipe
to tank farms nearby
at the same time us army engineers are
building a road to run inland from saada
heap
bypassing bangkok all together the road
provides a direct route northward from
the seaport
passing through areas in the heart of
the country where no roads existed
thailand has a problem in the physical
isolation
of substantial numbers of its people
from their own government
bulldozers are cutting through that
isolation
new world machinery cuts away the
ancient hillsides
as this road vital to defense against
communist subversion advances
it also opens the way to a richer life
for thousands who live in the
countryside
further north rough and difficult
terrain is forced to yield to this
modern highway
which will supply the needs of the
military and make rapid cross-country
movement possible
men and materiel for the big job come
from an engineer complex near korat
camp friendship at karat reflects the
size
and importance of the task
american units and outlying parts look
to camp friendship for support
and supply
it is coordinated by headquarters u.s
army support command
thailand as in most key areas of the
pacific
the army maintains modern sophisticated
communications
although most of thailand has a strong
sense of independence and loyalty to the
country
and is firmly anti-communist increasing
numbers of thai special forces
are undergoing intensive training to
counter small groups of communists
infiltrating the remote borders the
thais train to stop these insurgents
gaining control
over isolated areas of thailand
the thai special forces learn techniques
of counter insurgency
both in classrooms where the meaning and
theory are clearly established
and in the field where practical
operations are taught
by doing as co-members of the southeast
asia treaty organization
u.s and thai troops have jointly
participated in exercises
to sharpen defense against aggression in
operations like this
new and advanced techniques are learned
by all the allies
with each contributing from its
experience all military activities
including this exercise require massive
logistical support
and it is in support that the integrated
structure of user pack
comes into sharp focus
although routine supplies for the war in
vietnam
go directly from the united states to
vietnam critical supply requirements
are met from the army's forward base at
okinawa
this base also provides full supply
support to the army activities in
thailand
and backup maintenance support for all
army forces
in southeast asia
the important strategic location of this
forward base of operations
has given it the title keystone of the
pacific
one of the major commands on okinawa is
the second logistical command
the request from vietnam for the
urgently needed material required by
army units fighting a war
feed in here
swiftly the requests are handled with
the aid of modern electronic equipment
some of the requests for critical
supplies must be referred back to the us
the giant stockpile of materiel
maintained here by the second law of
command
fills many of the requests
but best though it is the job of
answering the urgent needs of war
in vietnam is only part of the story in
okinawa
the mission here is even broader to be
able to meet the projected and emergency
needs of army forces
throughout the pacific area in a command
where the constant enemy is distance
a concept of forward strategy is
essential
okinawa's contribution is manifest in
the warehouses
shops and storage areas with which the
island bristles
all this vital activity is served by
another link in the army communications
system
tactical forces on the island as well as
its logistical mission
advance okinawa's role in user packs
forward strategy special forces train
here
to meet the challenge of unconventional
warfare
recent history in the pacific has proven
clearly enough
the need for a guerrilla fighting
capability in our army
these troops train in the special skills
which give the army that capability
psychological warfare the battle for
men's minds
is waged in many ways radio programs are
beamed
behind enemy lines to reach the people
themselves
with news and information they would
otherwise be denied
to reinforce the message and to reach
others who do not have radios
psychological warfare operations
prepares millions of leaflets each month
for air drop these often comment on
current events
and show the lies of false enemy
propaganda
some leaflets encourage vietcong to
desert and use the leaflet as a safe
conduct pass
the effectiveness is clearly shown in
the fact that thousands of vietcong
use the safe conduct pass each month to
come over to our side
these men will not be firing weapons at
our soldiers
the paper war pays off
in all of user packs vast operations the
area on which the world's attention is
primarily focused
is vietnam
it was this land that the communists
chose as the test case
and springboard to the conquest of
southeast asia
faced with the rapid growth of a hot war
the manner in which the entire us army
was restructured
trained automated deployed under
restrictive peacetime rules
and fought will be recognized in future
years
as one of its greatest accomplishments
as the fighting grew heavier the army
had to expand its physical facilities
with millions of dollars worth of
construction of roads
ports depots airfields
barracks and operations facilities
they had to find faster ways to cross
jungles
today's dimension of battlefield
mobility would scarcely have been
credible
a decade ago this may well come to be
known as
the helicopter war
with the enemy's escalation of the war
the u.s countered with the response
which stemmed the tide
and steadily began turning it
the great build-up to turn that tide of
war
involves problems of logistics support
as great as the problem of combat
manpower
each month more than one half million
short tons of supplies
are brought into vietnam and distributed
through the major army ports in saigon
newport camaron bay and quinon
a strategic communications command unit
under the army
operates communications for all services
and government agencies
in vietnam
today in four major war zones over a
hundred maneuver battalions
infantry armor
artillery
and cavalry are seeking out and
destroying viet cong and north
vietnamese main forces
and bases
we are blowing up their decades-old
tunnel systems
the south vietnamese encouraged by
american achievements
cooperate increasingly in rooting out
the enemy
more and more enemy weapons supplies and
documents
are being captured
together with our allies the u.s
objective in vietnam today
remains what it has been from the
beginning to help the vietnamese people
achieve peace and stability and to
persuade the aggressors
both the vietcong insurgents and the
regular troops of north vietnam
both controlled by the government of
hanoi that their aggression
will not pay
by user packs forward deployments
throughout the pacific
of units trained and ready for combat
backed up by a ring of logistic spaces
the communist world has been told it can
go no further
in its march to world domination
the performance of the united states
army in vietnam
and throughout the pacific has made it
abundantly clear to the enemy
and the world that it is holding the
line for freedom
and will not be driven from the
battlefield
you